your job is to go to school
and be a good kid
not fight crime i'm a superhero one step
at a time that's why you're getting
training at biona so you can learn how
to control your powers
i'm seven you need training
i'll see you in action
the kid is something else
when we figure out how to harness power
dna i mean can you imagine what are you
talking about we're here to help these
people not exploit them
all right class we've got a brand new
student i think we're going to be best
friends
something weird going on
this time
[Music]
something terrible is coming
dion is growing up you need to trust him
we got a monster problem
i want to try and do justice i'm gonna
have to fight it
every powered person is at risk as long
as that thing is out there
[Music]
[Music]
will you please state your name for the
record
please welcome pamela anderson
did you know anything at all about mr
lee before you met him
i knew he was the drummer for mommy crew
did you find him attractive i like to
smile
i still do
[Music]
we're so good together
to everlasting love
we have recently come into possession of
a piece of material
[Music]
this is so private it's like we're
seeing something we're not supposed to
be safe
nobody's ever getting richer for
celebrity sex tape what if we sold it
someplace nobody could find us a website
a website it's this thing on the
computer people will order the tape
directly from us
wow you are so hot
what the hell is this
how many copies of this are out there
could be doesn't
high-rated copies are sprouting up all
over the web you don't seem to
understand what a big deal this is i'm
on that tape just the same as you but
this is worse for me how is this worse
for you
everyone looks beautiful and perfect is
that how you feel like you have to
please people that's all i do
this side of the planet
seems less intent on killing our
children
father once said to me
if you pretend to be something long
enough
eventually
you'll no longer need to pretend
i feel we're becoming too human
[Music]
to be the parents that our children
deserve
we have to think of the future now
[Music]
you need to form your own ideas when the
trust passes the baton you'll be the one
to take it
i'm gonna convert them all one at a time
if i have to
i miss being able to believe that
there's someone out there listening
someone with the power to make things
all better
when are we going to tell them what we
discovered
[Music]
i have to keep my children safe
i am the prophet nothing can stand
against me
to be worthy of souls love children you
only need faith
and that is one thing that this robot
can never take away from us
love
be the death of us all
what fun we're going to have today
so
serenity's cutest couple is back on
track what i'm looking forward to is the
morning i can wake up with you in my
arms is something going on with youtube
that i should know about when did you
two become a peer hovering hannah's how
do you feel about them fighting over you
excited
maddie dana sue
my sisters
you haven't even told me why you took
your brother's car you could have died
tell me what you know about your birth
parents i just want to know whose eyes
are staring back at me every single time
i look in the mirror when are you gonna
start taking responsibility for the
habit did you wreak in people's lives
ever talk to anybody ronnie no because i
haven't even talked to ronnie about
ronnie
after wading through all of the hurt i'm
starting to see that
[Applause]
[Music]
there's so much more to you than the
game more than you've ever realized i am
really glad that we get to spend more
time together would you mind terribly if
i kissed you right here i cannot imagine
going through this without having this
you never have to go through anything
big or small on your own
life will surprise you and so will your
ability to remember the sweetest moments
all right
[Music]
jack reacher has deceased a tight army
bronze star silver star and a purple
heart what in god's name is a guy like
that doing in margrave what's a guy like
that doing in jail zip ties
cuffs didn't fit him you guys recycle
seven bodies since you set foot in my
town
i was arrested for murder now you want
my help i want you to do what i say you
just go wherever you want whenever you
want everyone's always jealous i'm gonna
uncover this whole operation
and burn it to the ground
you boys know what's about to happen to
you you leave now
[Music]
i don't go getting yourself arrested for
murder
shooter with someone who knows firearms
well enlighten me bullets were 95 grain
that's subsonic this wasn't a first
timer these people are connected and
stone cold killers
so be smart don't break the law and
promise me you won't end up in another
holding cell
no
yeah you got it looking for payback
payback
justice vengeance
looking for the whole gang
you're gonna kill a whole lot of people
aren't you already started
[Music]
you're about to get your ass kicked no
i'm just gonna break the hands of three
drunk kids there's four of us one of
you's got to drive to the hospital
[Music]
it's not a twist off
[Music]
show off
[Music]
natalie thompson
[Music]
i know you've already
but
been
the sake of the camera you sure you
don't want legal representation i don't
need it i can tell you that you've been
arrested on suspicion of conspiracy to
abduct leo newman
nope there's obviously been some sort of
misunderstanding we can't be certain
whether this is terrorist related
politically motivated or simple
extortion
young guy leo newman gets packed into a
suitcase by a masked gang
nypd flags four suspects
katherine newman i cannot imagine what
you're going through at the moment i
love my son
and i want him back
we're being set up
by us
i don't know why what do we have in
common we're all british
and we're all in new york on the daily
only one was kidnapped
do we look like kidnappers do you what
does a kidnapper look like
you
without any proof of our innocence the
damage is already done
i can fix this
are you sure you know what you're doing
no i can't go back nobody buys me as a
mother
i'll always be a ceo
long there's no other option
first page in the playbook except i
don't remember the chapter on the kidnap
of your only child
[Music]
you're being asked to communicate in
order to free your lonely child these
people want you to tell the truth we're
getting deeper in there is still a
chance that people may understand
everything you've done until now
you have underestimated these people
right from the beginning
[Applause]
the truth will come out
[Music]
and this crazy white boy
saves your alleged gun jamming ass
and just bounce with your paper and
drugs
like casper the ghost
what did you find out about the mystery
man
new york is over
this is my chance
[Music]
a guy like me
you work for i work for nobody i'm a
free agent well to flynn
you made quite an impression on my
family
in a town
like this out here trying to make money
and moves
you clocking my city it gonna be a
problem if i am
you don't want to stick around to find
out
let's find out then
[Music]
i ain't even been in this city long
enough to have any enemies
i got three three enemies that's
definitely it
you're definitely a man's blooded blood
man alone don't last long in these
streets i'll take care of it
[Music]
you're not afraid of hell sometimes i
think i'm already there
[Music]
welcome to chicago tommy
look boys home sweet home
attention dreamland it's me your mighty
queen bean
are you ready to welcome us
boys hey don't worry there's no way they
can hit us from this high up
lots of people would like to take over
this castle somewhere within these walls
the rest are out here the elves are up
to something dreamland castle is
rightfully ours we'll take it by force
please gasp
hello bean
i've been having nightmares again
what this is castle something about it
intensifies dreams
you're sitting in the very center of the
known world i'm sorry move over a couple
of inches there you go
dagmar's back every twist and turn in
your ridiculous life that was all me
the debt to hell is about to be repaid
let the wedding begin
i didn't see that coming suspense that's
how they hook you
your breakfast your majesty
bean wake up
late night bunny
oh yeah
dreamlanders don't deserve a fate like
this
no matter how annoying and stubborn and
dirty they are i've got to save my
people who's with me
the crickets have spoken
you're too gabby no either we all
survive or none of us do that's the deal
that's not the deal we made a deal no we
did not i'm sure we did i signed a
prenup secretly that says what we break
up i don't know i can't read
you gotta stop focusing on revenge and
anger and wrath instead just focus on
what matters the most and that's murder
i'll return it dude what you smiling
about it's just gonna take longer
it's not your typical london one bed
it's
amazing
what's he like
the man who built this
he interviews prospective tenants
personally
we need to find the right fit
but perhaps we've found her
my houses make demands of people the
housekeeper system gathers data from
whoever lives a full gate street to
improve the user experience
living in a different way a different
place i think it will help are you sure
about this
why wouldn't i be
how are you finding it here the house
and i are a good match for each other
and the man who built it could you be a
good match for each other
emma i will love you forever
here's emma
do you know anything about the young
woman who lived here before
emma matthews
how well did you know her
yeah she looks just like you
same eyes same jawline you look like her
this has hallmarks of repetition
compulsion acting out the same
psychodrama with new players allotted
the same role
we have these rules for a reason they
are there to help us do the right thing
even when it's hard are we just objects
to be replaced whenever we do something
you don't like
i need to understand how this relates to
me and to emma you agree to live here
under certain words your wife life just
doesn't work like that then you make it
work like that if it is a pattern it may
not be over
hello
for
somebody's taking my
place
okay newbies you're up five six ready
arch those backs kitties am i doing this
wrong i feel like velma's searching for
her glasses
so you know how we're nowhere near the
places we thought we'd be in our lives
we spent the last part of our official
youth stuck inside just here watering
house plants
you have too many plants
i saw west today jewels i didn't see you
you were hiding behind a stack of
containers that are made out of clear
plastic are we actually seeing jules
sexually frustrated i feel like i'm in
eighth grade well i can tell you what i
did in eighth grade and it involved
ruining several electric toothbrushes
very graphic
[Music]
my life is going nowhere nowhere hiya
kittens and here we go again where are
they all going they're all taking
flights to their future just like you
two have to do good luck figuring out
where you want to go dollface
today is the start of the new chapter
for us i went to business school to
become an entrepreneur and we're putting
up a bar for women a bar with rosie on
tap somewhere where you can yell at the
tv while watching the bachelor i just
heard the words rose ambassador in the
same sentence so yes to whatever that's
for
[Music]
i have decided to work hard and see
where it takes me i will mentor you yes
i have perfect skin and i'm wildly
successful but what is my legacy that
sounded pretty good
who was that he was clearly hitting on
you i thought my days of being attracted
to straight men were behind me and yet
here we are
you texted a guy without my input into
it
so what do we think of jules opening
here how did that make you all feel bad
oh he might not remember my name let me
just no no no no
who thinks sending a gift just now was a
weird move
i need a drink pop that [ __ ]
that's how friends work
even if it's hard you trust each other
and you show up remind me again why you
needed us for this
if i had one what kind of do you think
i'd have
circumcised is it like shoes do you need
to walk around the store a little make
sure it's comfortable curve or no curve
these are the questions
[Music]
i might have a story her name is anna
delvey or anna sorokin no one's sure
she's either on rich german heiress or
she's flat broke the charges are insane
anna committed real white-collar
felonies while posing as a socialite in
an attempt to steal millions of dollars
hi anna
i just had some questions
i have a question
what's you wearing you look poor
she has everything that is wrong with
america right now
i am famous
people are penting a public picture of
me as a criminal
that's not my story and what is your
story
i'm a cold yes i'm a cold piece anna
came to new york no rich parents no
connections sometimes you gotta fake it
till you make it now we get to the good
part
you have to work hard to get what you
want i've always known that i'm building
something as a private club a step
beyond the vip room it's 40 million to
finance we have two banks interested in
loaning her the money
holy [ __ ]
to building something special
40 million dollar loan how in the hell
does that happen
do it
do it
if you stop thinking about me like
everyone else like basic you know
what do you guys think most expensive
resorts in morocco i realized the clues
were there all along she put it all on
my cart
give me back that money please why you
being like this is so dramatic
image money power everyone is hustling
real hot girl
every day men do far worse things than
anything i've allegedly done
anna stole a jet what's going on who are
you
anna delvey is a masterpiece [ __ ] and
they can just all right
yes i'm a cold piece looking for mr
freeze to get froze like me
this time we try to make you forget
who you are
and where you came from
[Applause]
don't let her do that
dale
jeffrey thompson house manager
whoa
10 years of a long time let me show you
around with em dimes at hillary
let's go find you something fit for a
friend
what do you think i made you love
[Music]
yo
uncle phil
i'm glad you're safe we'll talk later
yo is this really baby ashley you're a
long way from home well all too how you
been
you know
thriving
[Applause]
i hope uh one day we can talk about why
you're really here
[Music]
do you know why i'm here from philly
scrapping the ball court
[Music]
got nasty
now some bad man from philly he wanted
to deal with you
why move mountains to give you here
so here's the story
came to bel air for a better education
simple
be patient
give this a real chance
we have a different set of rules here
okay
if you want to do well just keep your
head down and follow my lead whoa whoa
man you know i'm a west philly wherever
i go yo king what's up man
no love
look around
these are my people
what that one steer clear
welcome to bel air
what the hell is my life yo chill out
bro
maybe will just isn't cut out for this
why are we working so hard to save a boy
who doesn't want to be safe
[Music]
a real man takes responsibility for his
actions
a real man knows when to let go of his
pride and make the most out of a second
chance
be the will who charmed west philly with
his talent and swag let the music defuse
all attention
[Music]
get out my face
[Music]
and also i got cody on the camera
round fence right there man that's got
to an argument in the car y'all feel
like you disrespected me man tried to
say i wasn't a genius [ __ ] but who are
you to call yourself a genius
[Applause]
they're doing documentary
[Music]
very rarely do you encounter
self-contained people
this man can do everything himself
he's living it
so he's like god saying
i'm about to hand you the world
just know at any given time i can take
it away from you
[Music]
general nerd it's been suggested that
you are unstable incompetent fragile
eccentric indecisive and potentially
treasonous when you point a finger
you have three fingers pointed back at
you and your thumb
stands erect pointed towards the sky
i would like to hear a space for spirit
on three one two three space horse
spirit ah
you will have five months to prove
yourself or potus will install
alternative commands
watch it closely and see if if it shows
jesus
got you [ __ ]
space horse isn't going anywhere
we are back in the game oh my god
what's going on with us this is
now oh i'm just gonna blow this
interview no you won't what have you
done for you
showtime baby
give me a hit of that jive parsley
are you sure yeah
hitman
[Music]
whatever happened on the moon stays on
the moon
we came here to make a deal general
brand new magnificent bastard thank you
sir
hello captain lancaster how are you no i
miss i miss earth and uh my family
and food
and uh standing up and gravity and you
know
apparently my heart has shrunken a
little bit hey how are my how are my new
york jets doing you have to tell me jess
oh
[Music]
mugsy
what we need is a little fun and
adventure
i'm evil cuphead i'm not so sure you
know what i do and i'm not so sure i
double down
what does that even mean
let me introduce you to some friends of
mine
[Applause]
[Music]
i stuff it when they
the
rub
it's time for a double down
i hate those [ __ ]
you guys want an evening you'll never
forget
[Music]
nothing but trouble we love trouble
we go
[Music]
oh get that cup
oh shut up
[Music]
hello my name is mark s
[Music]
and i have of my own free accord
elected to undergo the procedure
known as severance
i give consent to sever my memories
between my work life
and my personal life
i acknowledge that once the procedure is
complete i will be unable to access my
personal memories whilst on the severed
floor say gratitude
nor will i retain work memories faith
sorry when i return home
at the end of the day
i make these statements freely
hi kids what's for dinner we warned you
about the greeting you were kidding we
hate it how many reasons did we come up
with eight
good morning hi mr middle check mark
could i have a word
petey
is no longer with this company i'm sorry
mark you guys are one of my favorite
office friendships what happened we'd
love to tell you but unfortunately
non-disclosure policy forbids i confer
upon you the advanced role of department
chief congratulations a handshake is
available upon request
thank you may i have a handshake
do i know you my name's petey i'm from
work
so we're friends
i'm your best friend
nothing
is what they say
i used to think it would take a monster
to put someone in a place like that
office
especially if the person was himself
if you want to know what's going on down
there
you'll find the beginning of a very long
answer
what's happening
what is it we actually do here
[Music]
it's important your eyes be kind do you
know how to make your eyes kind of
[Music]
can we talk business of course so past
us behind us shy who one less what [ __ ]
him moving forward we need a game plan
agreed
here she is boys
you know what's great about me your
humility no it's when i'm me
here she is world
no more opening act gigs what i will
only do gigs where i can say what i want
that's what lenny would do
that's different he's lenny bruce well
then make me lenny bruce make me a
headliner
how am i supposed to do that if i can't
even book you i don't know you're my
manager manage me
that's not how the business works
then let's change the business ready or
not
here comes mama
[Music]
stay tuned
where's your entourage i'm kind of doing
the college moving thing solo
i'll come to the ring sing
everything's girl new i miss you hi
jordan bye jordan it's time to get into
some trouble
college is about starting over right
brand new damon lives here you were just
a little too excited about that shimmer
in here
she loves you man that much is clear
[Applause]
you are looking at the new face of hbcu
baseball
this entire program rests on that boy's
shoulders
handle your business it's like what if
i'm not good enough it's basically
you're scared every damn day bro
whatever you wrote
all american homecoming new series
premieres monday february 21st free next
day only on the cw app
four
three
two
one
[Music]
sir i know who's behind this it's her
arms trafficker
keen military strategist
she runs an international organization
of soldiers for hire
loyal to no country
[Music]
miss federovo
you were brought here to discuss
105 criminal charges against you
i can't wait
you worked so hard to know me but you
know nothing my bank just got hit by six
gunmen
they sent a message
out of the queen
who's the queen check your pocket
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
have i got your attention
why is she in custody she's been
operating for years
why now
agents valerie turner i've been hoping
to meet you i was untouchable until you
you're impressive federer of this plan
is bigger than the banks she led you to
her you give her a lot of credit i'm not
sure you give her enough looks like an
office building but inside it's a
fortress if i'm federova
i hit it next
you have no idea who you're dealing with
for what it's worth
we are going to be partners
i have a story to tell you
i took over seven banks
but not
[Music]
what's in motion will eclipse you the
fbi and the government
you're going to learn a lot agent turner
[Music]
first time i met you said to myself this
young man has the war inside
franklin we're glad you got your own
dreams
but they're not ours
swear to me you will do everything you
have to do to protect our baby i promise
this right here is what it's all about
family
in my absence you decided that you
should make yourself a middleman
inside of your own organization
lapd they've gotten worse
the crackdown on my people's been brutal
police come at us we gonna come right
back at them
find somebody to serve up
i ain't no snitch
this empire
it's gonna crumble
i'm trying to help you franklin and help
keep the peace
turn astrid up yeah
i don't want to put my life at risk but
your [ __ ] has decisions there is
nothing i'm not prepared to do
nothing tears a family apart like money
fx's snowfall premieres february 23rd on
fx stream on hulu
[Music]
i hear drums
no
shields
[Applause]
you
have been summoned here
to avenge the death of vikings
[Music]
bring me
england
this flight
it's not my blood
it is our blood
it is viking blood
[Music]
i'm really sorry
[Music]
[Music]
i have to kill you
[Music]
you